another bag of semolina goes into the hopper at
the prince macaroni manufacturing company plant
in Lowell Massachusetts it'll become part
of the 250,000 miles of spaghetti macaroni
and egg noodles turned out here every day
here we see noodle dough emerging from the
mixer in a wide sheet about a quarter
of an inch thick now it'll be rolled
much thinner and in the case of this batch
stamped out in a shape called small bows
the Bose dropout below into a chute
leading to a conveyor that will carry
them away to a dryer the more familiar egg
noodles are rolled cut and shaped like this
and here's how macaroni is extruded squeezed
out like toothpaste from a tube there's a pin
in the center of each opening to give the
macaroni its hole now it too will be dry
spaghetti and spaghetti knee also extruded
but without the whole of course are draped
over poles for drying in former times
the spaghetti was sold in the shape of
a shepherd's crook now the curved part
is cut off for better packaging there
have been some other changes in recent
years machines now speed the operation
and keep prices low while the protein content
has been increased and starch content reduced
away it goes to be packaged a precise amount
is weighed out like this but the
rest of the operation is automatic
and here's the result at one time predominantly
an Italian dish spaghetti is now a universal faith